- [Interviewer] Hey, Jasmine.
Jasmine, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Well, I was born in Inglewood
but I wasn't born in the hospital
and then I ended up being
raised in the foster care system
because my mother passed away in '93.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was a baby still
and I ended up living
with my grandmother first,
and they ended up taking me
at nine from my grandmother
because she was being abusive,
and they put me in the foster care system
from nine to 18.
But when I was a baby
I already had a CPS worker
and all that so yeah.
- [Interviewer] So most
of your childhood was-
- Yes, foster-
- [Interviewer] Foster and jumping around.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And where was dad?
- My dad was in and out of prison
and he ended up passing away too as well.
(People shouting outside)
- [Interviewer] Sorry. (laughs)
- It's okay.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood
with your grandmother and the foster home?
- Well, with my grandmother,
she was abusive.
I was always getting beat,
and that's what made the
worker come and take me
and remove me from her,
into an actual foster home with
a foster mother and family.
And growing up in the foster home,
my foster mom, she was
an ordained minister.
And in the beginning everything
was okay and whatnot.
But as I started getting
older, she started
saying how I was going to be a prostitute,
how I'm gonna die at an early age,
how my own blood family
is gonna disown me,
how guys are going to beat on me.
To where, when I graduated high school
and I left from her home,
I believed it.
So everything that she said
that was gonna happen to me,
except death, has happened.
Like, guys will beat on me,
I became a prostitute,
Because that's all I wanted when I left.
My family disowned me,
and I came close to death.
I got shot by a client with a BB gun.
And so I have buck shots,
and broken fragments in
my face because of it.
But I fought harder.
It's very, very hard
- [Interviewer] What age did
start working in the street?
- 18, fresh out of high school.
- [Interviewer] Do work for the pimp,
or on your own?
- When I first got out, I had (Indistinct)
which was a pimp,
and it didn't work out with him.
I started trying to do
the 'renegade' thing.
I couldn't do it.
And then I ended up meeting another guy,
and I was with him for a long time,
but it was hard to get away from him too.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested for this?
- Yes, I have.
Too many times. (laughs)
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
part of the picture for you?
- Yes.
Yes it is.
- [Interviewer] What drugs do you use?
- Crystal
I never would have thought that
I would be doing that.
You get what I'm saying?
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- I have four
- [Interviewer] And are you raising them?
- No.
I have two boys and two girls.
Two of them, got taken to the system,
because one of my family
members told on me.
And then the other two, I
just had one in November.
She's with my sister.
And then my one year old is with his dad.
So they're with family, the last two
- [Interviewer] Does
doing this for a living
get you down sometimes?
- It does.
It really does.
It's scary,
because you never know,
whose car are you going to get into.
Like I said, I got shot before,
Not knowing.
You get what I'm saying?
It's depressing sometimes.
You go through a lot.
You never know
like I said, whose car
you're gonna get into?
You never know what's
going to happen to you.
And it's a lot that comes with the life.
You know?
- [Interviewer] You've
been beaten up and raped?
- I've been beaten up.
I've been raped before,
at gunpoint.
Came close to death numerous times
by the hands of a pimp and a client.
It's scary, you know?
- [Interviewer] What was your relationship
with the pimp like?
- In the beginning it was okay.
But then he uses too.
And it got to the point to where
he used to choke me to where
I'd start foaming at the mouth.
He'd beat me.
His girl-
I have stab wounds on my arm.
And then when I was pregnant,
his girl stabbed me right
here when I was pregnant
I tried to run from him.
He ended up finding me,
and it just went downhill basically.
And it took a lot for me to
get away from him, you know?
And by that, I ended up
going to where I'm at now.
And because I don't have a pimp,
and I'm working in
someone's hood basically,
they're taxing me.
They see that I don't have nobody.
And they don't like
the 'renegading' thing.
So one of the guys there, he beats on me,
he makes me give him money.
And he says, if I don't, he's
gonna crack my skull open.
The other day he stomped me out.
All types of stuff-
- [Interviewer] You told me last night.
- Recently, yeah.
Well, like a couple of days ago
he pulled me out of someone's
car and stomped me out,
then last night he socked me
and knocked me out last night.
- [Interviewer] What hours
are you typically working?
- It depends.
Sometimes from,
like 11 in the afternoon.
And I'll go back and
forth and I'll go outside,
and I'll be outside to
like maybe one on and off.
And then I'll go in when
the police gets hot.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is it
competitive out on the street
with all the girls out there?
- It used to be when I used
to work the other interstate
like in the 60s, because
it's a lot of competition.
That's why I ended up going
down towards Imperial,
because I don't like to
be around a lot of girls.
Because I feel like that's my competition.
When I'm on another end, where
there's not too many girls,
I make my money.
It's better for me that way.
So yeah.
- [Interviewer] When you were younger,
did you have dreams of doing
something else with your life?
- Medical assistant.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- I graduated high school.
Then I ended up going to Kaplan
and I took the medical assisting test
to be a medical assistant
to go to school for it.
I passed it.
Then I found out I was
pregnant with my kid,
my first daughter, and I never went back.
- [Interviewer] And what
stops you from doing it now?
Because you're still young.
- Yeah, um.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 29.
- [Interviewer] You can still do it.
- I can.
It's just being in the streets.
It will take for me to have to get
out of the area and get away from,
to get my mind right I feel like.
Because I know I have it in me, you know?
It's just the drugs and I've
been doing this for so long.
So it's kind of hard sometimes, you know?
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- When I got shot in my face with a BB gun
I went on an out call,
not knowing it was more than
one person in the house.
And when I went in there,
the guy took me down the hallway.
And when I came to the first room,
it was another guy standing by the closet.
And someone told me to
turn around and run.
But as soon as I turned around to run
I heard a "BOOM!".
Next thing I'm on the floor,
and I feel like a whole
bunch of warm stuff
coming out of my head.
And come to find out,
he shot me with a-
I think the doctor said a gauge?
It shot out multiple buck
shots and it sprayed me.
So I have Buck shots and broken fragments
all in my face.
They ended up leaving, the two guys.
Then my friend that was outside
heard it, came in,
and they called 9-1-1.
And where we were, there
wasn't no trauma center.
So they had to call the helicopter
and had to airlift me from-
It was Blythe, California,
to Palm Springs Regional.
I almost died because of it.
But now I'm stuck with broken
fragments and buck shots,
still in my face.
- [Interviewer] Could've
lost your eyes right?
- I could've.
One actually missed my eye right here.
It's like, literally like
right here by my eye.
It missed my eye.
And all through here, I have
Broken fragments and a whole
bunch of Buck shots in my face.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- When I had my kids.
- [Interviewer] When you had your kids?
It just, you know, makes me happy.
But now that they're not with
me, it kinda sucks, you know?
But I know they're
taken care of, you know?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever talk to them?
- No, I can't talk to them.
Two of them,
I don't know where they're at
because they got adopted out.
And my last two,
they're too young to talk.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- I have
- My ex folks that I had ran
from, I was in love with him,
but I seen the things
that he was doing to me
and it hurt me.
And it took a lot for me
to get over that, you know?
Because he knows there's
no feelings in life.
There's no feelings, but
I've been in love before.
- [Interviewer] And
doing this for a living
kinda makes that difficult, right?
- Yeah, it does.
A lot of people don't respect
working girls, you know?
they look down on us.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
They don't realize you
have a heart and a soul
and a story.
- Or what we go through
If they were to put
themselves in our shoes.
Or sit and ask us.
Like just talk to us, period.
They always assume things.
You get what I'm saying?
Instead of sitting there
and asking the person,
or talking to a person,
they wanna think this person is like this.
But not until you sit and you ask me,
or anything.
you're not going to know nothing about me,
or why I am the way I am.
That's where people get me twisted.
They think I'm a bad person or
they think I'm this, I'm that
But they never sit down and ask me
or talk to me to figure
out who I really am.
- [Interviewer] Alright, Jasmine.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
And good luck with everything.
I would love to see you
back with your kids.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thanks, bye.